oh my god youtubers we finally got some
more spider-man homecoming that just
pretty much guarantees they're going to
be dropping the official trailer with
rogue one in a couple weeks
what what are you hey I'm Peter
so this is Brazil comic-con it was
basically like a short clip from
spider-man's perspective he starts
swinging around then he's talking to
happy Hogan Jon Favreau's back badge
badge
bad guys I put him on the toilet come on
if you guys remember him from the Iron
Man movies he's technically only Iron
Man's driver but he's kind of like the
confidant which actually reminds me I'm
actually going to be doing an Iron Man
spider-man giveaway so all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video is for a
comixology gift certificate for about
$30 be sure to turn alerts on because
there's going to be a whole bunch of
Spider Man dropping really soon they
were able to convince Jon Favreau to
come out of hiding he's been directing
movies so it's not like he's been doing
nothing but I know everybody's hoping
that he's going to come back and direct
Iron Man for eventually you know who
knows what that'll end up happening but
hopefully the Marvel Illuminati and
Robert Downey jr. can convince him but
then they jump to a couple other clips
there's Tony Stark giving spider-man a
giant suit upgrade in this big start
tech briefcase then you see him jump off
a building with the classic webbing
underneath his arms so they're going for
some super deep cuts with Marvel's
version of spider-man it's going to be
so awesome I know it doesn't seem like
there's a whole lot of Iron Man in the
movie just the way people have been
talking about it you probably heard
about the way Marvel is treating the
Hulk in all these films like they're
giving him what is essentially his own
movie just spread out over a couple
different movies because of the weird
rights situation with Universal
obviously they don't have that problem
with Iron Man it's just that Robert
Downey jr. is waiting for the right
story to come along and he's so
expensive that they want to make sure if
they're gonna do another Iron Man story
that it's just gonna blow up Captain
America Civil War style and for the most
part Iron Man is kind of at a low moment
right now so it looks like he's throwing
himself into mentoring young Peter
Parker as walnut date loads go that
wasn't bad Oh what do we have here a
retro tech huh
drift story Salvation Army if not
full-blown adopting him I don't think
they'll ever do that but they'll just
he'll flirt with that idea like they'll
make you feel like Tony Stark is
emotionally adopting spider-man just
like spider-man will emotionally adopt
Tony Stark you can just imagine the
headline aging lonely billionaire
adopted by Widow and nephew so you've
seen a lot of Iron Man films you can
amass
what his scenes are going to be like in
the film like that scene in Civil War
was so telling the way you know it was
kind of funny meant to be a little off
handed casual but there was also a lot
of heart in it too like Iron Man's been
through a lot of [ __ ]
so has Peter Parker as of now like he
starts to tell the Uncle Ben's story
when he first meets Tony but they kind
of stop it short but also in that same
way they're kind of using Doctor Strange
very sparingly in other people's films
the same thing is going to happen with
Iron Man and the Hulk it's just like the
Hulk I think it's going to be a much
much bigger part of Thor Ragnarok
because there's been so little of him so
far and there's been so much of Iron Man
but you sort of talk about how Peter
Parker resembles Tony Stark just a
little bit like he's a future scientist
this shirt that he's wearing just gives
you an idea for the tone of the humor
too the physics is theoretical but the
fun is real so he's just like a branch
off of the Tony Stark tree I can't wait
to see their scenes together just see
them try to out quit each other
spider-man is king of quipping but
Robert Downey jr. is Iron Man is king of
quipping in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so then they jump between a
couple of the other people in the movie
some of the villains just like some of
the big action set-pieces
there was a vulture action set piece
that was in the comic-con trailer they
kind of put a little bit of that in
there
Iron Man is going to have to help him
out just because the shocker is also in
the movie there was a little bit of
Michelle Ned leads the other people at a
school like Flash Thompson in a little
bit from the funny bank heist save where
he takes down people who are dressed up
like The Avengers it's like this really
hilarious heist
we're like a bunch of thugs dress up
like the core Avengers from that first
Avengers film in spider-man's like I
just got done hanging out with you guys
you were definitely not my friends so
he'll have like a couple small funny
saves then you have the really big
vulture stuff that's going on in the
movie but I just love the idea that Tony
Stark is helping to make him whole
spider-man again
like you've had a bunch of different
versions of the character before there
been a lot of stories about how Andrew
Garfield felt like he failed the
character which is kind of a bummer but
I think you know what Marvel and Sony
are intending to do with this
arrangement is just bring bad
a lot of depth and meaning to the
character like a deeper message Andrew
Garfield's criticism of his own version
of spider-man was that it was kind of
hollow like it was perpetuating that
type of Michael Bay filming with all
show no feeling behind it so Mart you
know Marvel is just trying to infuse a
lot of the emotion that you felt like
the first time you read a spider-man
comic into this movie so that's why I
feel like we should all be freaking out
about it but yeah there's going to be
like a ton of really awesome action
scenes in it too and this is only the
first movie in a trilogy so if you
didn't know they did confirm that
spider-man is getting a new trilogy that
will follow him through high school they
haven't fully explained how the
timelines going to work only that Kevin
Feige was likening it to the Harry
Potter franchise the way it followed him
through school right up to the end so
he'll be graduating in that final film
but that doesn't mean that he's not
going to be doing Avenger stuff in
between we have the infinity war films
so there'll be all kinds of stuff
happening it's just that spider-man's
age will keep him a teenager through
these films so you're not going to get
like a 16 year old spider-man in
spider-man homecoming which is actually
where it picks up he's a sophomore in
high school
cut to the next movie where he's 26 with
a 5 o'clock shadow but not to stomp all
over Tobey Maguire because I actually
really did enjoy those movies when I saw
them but they did joke about putting
some dancing in the movie just because
Tom Holland is actually a really good
performer and he's actually very
acrobatic so given that the homecoming
dance spider-man homecoming all these
things bleed together there might be
like a little bit of dancing somewhere
in the film but if you have watched the
other spider-man movies even like the
Tobey Maguire movies you know that the
role that Norman Osborn occupies in
spider-man's life because of Harry
Osborn he becomes this big bill he's
kind of like an evil version of Tony
Stark so what they've done in spider-man
homecoming is they've given that role to
Michael Keaton's vulture but that
doesn't mean that he is like Norman
Osborn he's just a big villain who
constructs a flight suit like that's how
his wings work they just decided that
Marvel is just kind of flows a lot from
stark tech it's all technology-based
there aren't a lot of metahumans or even
mutants you know because they can't use
the word mutants because of the Fox
films so that doesn't mean that they're
never going to do Green Goblin it just
means
they wanted to do different characters
that they haven't done before in this
first new spider-man film in fun fact if
you want to know why they redid the
origin story like they essentially did
the exact same story when they rebooted
spider-man with Andrew Garfield Kevin
Feige actually clarified that that was a
rights issue that was part of the way
that Sony was allowed to keep making
spider-man films they had to do an
origin story so that's kind of
ridiculous but that's just kind of the
way that contracts work out with big
Hollywood studios so thankfully now
because of this Marvel arrangement they
don't have to redo the uncle band origin
story you pick up with Peter being
spider-man for a while they'll probably
address Uncle Ben like he won't be
completely absent from the film but
they're not just going to redo the
origin story again so just a reminder
that the spider-man trailer is supposed
to be attached to rogue one that's what
everybody seems to be saying I haven't
seen any official confirmation from
Marvel but they typically don't confirm
stuff like that like usually they don't
comment but that's going to be in two
weeks and I will be doing a bunch of
rogue one videos too but James Gunn also
revealed that they've finished the new
guardians of the galaxy trailer he did
not confirm when they're dropping that
but it might also drop with Star Wars
rogue one so what's going to happen next
is I'll post a new Rick and Morty video
then I'll post a video for next season's
big flash arrow legends big crossover so
get hype it's going to be a really good
weekend there's a whole bunch of comic
book stuff happening this weekend while
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for all the big DC week
videos that I did for the big crossover
and you can click here to rewatch the
guardians of the galaxy 2 trailer so
everybody high-five I'll see you guys in
a little bit
you